what I just described to you now has
become my practice of how I will be what
I want to leave when I leave the planet
that's it
this episode is proudly sponsored by CM
Bois many of you watching have heard of
Tristan Harris in the Center for Humane
technology we've done many episodes on
the perverse incentives around screen
time and critically thinking about what
balance truly maximizes our potential
Sampo built a new smartphone interface
and browser extensions as the new home
screen for humanity they're at a
crossroads looking for a new CEO to come
in or to partner with a larger
organization that has the resources to
bring this incredible technology to the
world they've built a high integrity
foundation and are teed up for something
wonderful if interested message the
founder Andrew done at Andrew at cm poco
more infos in the bio thanks everyone
and enjoy the episode
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host on sakya we're on site at
the beautiful old transformative
technology conference for a second
annual partnership with them we are now
speaking with John CAMAC hi John hello
everyone
thanks for coming on the program my
pleasure I'm so pumped to dive into
things with you let's start things off
one of our favorite questions we love
asking our guests are we really all one
well I would do it yes and no and maybe
ladies and gentlemen it's a trick
question I'm not sure we're gonna find
out aren't we I think we all have common
DNA I think we may have a common
spiritual connectedness but I also think
part of the joy of life is being an
individual in the oneness and becoming
more defined in a self because if you
become more defined in a self where you
know what your boundaries are you're
actually less anxious and then you have
more capacity to act on your principles
in the world so I kind of like the
duality of this interesting there's
connectivity but there should also be
individuality and we need to honor that
individuality while we'd also find ways
to share values and common causes so
then there is this constant feeling on a
moment-to-moment basis of deep
interconnectedness and deep unity and
oneness yet at the same time we carry
this also this unique blueprint that we
have of bringing some sort of a gift
some sort of a contribution to to our
world and we carry those simultaneously
well I think the I believe human beings
had more good than bad I believe that
human beings are seeking ways to be good
I believe some people were never
they never learned the lessons they
needed and I live in Baltimore Maryland
and Baltimore is a challenge city and I
deal with those social issues is kind of
a civically minded person working in
community and I don't judge people on
their behavior because I think in many
cases they never learned how to let
their goodness be Express because they
were under threat from when they were
very young so I think finding the
goodness and then how do you bring it
into kind of your principles of right
action and to the extent I have a little
Buddhist in me the right action is
something that I've worked to develop
and I work to have it be an exercise
that I always have it available to me in
this conversation and whatever decisions
I make after I leave this interview when
I go home to my wife when I meet
somebody on the street and I think that
is a capacity that can be nurtured and I
think the this conference when I look at
all the interesting engineering and
technology I can think of it as we're
shifting brain waves we're doing this
and that but I think are we giving
people the ability to be calm enough to
have that conversation with themselves
where they find what's to be right and
true for themselves where their higher
self can become more available in their
relationship in the day to day life's
lives that they're living what about
your own personal experiences with those
deep states of interconnectedness or
eagle' loss or unconditional love the
present nests I've had them as a young
man I was enamored by an individual
called Edgar Cayce
and he's kind of gone out of favor but I
viewed him as kind of the American
almost like Presbyterian psychic he was
grew up in a Christian tradition but as
a young man he was able to go into a
trance state and from that he began to
provide readings to people he did
thousands of readings he had a
scenographer who recorded them they've
been cross-referenced and he he opened
my eyes to the fact that there are
altered states that we can reach and
probably higher orders of consciousness
I think part of my life has been trying
to see how much of that higher state I
can reach but not to just be a voyeur
where I go have the experience but by
how much kind of integrated so it's that
awareness or that I don't know if I'd
call it a capacity I think I would call
it a creating the way through a
meditation practice where there's some
of a lability to it right so you can be
reminded or you can create reference
points in your life so you get the
contextual choices we all have every day
framed in a way that is less about me
being reactive or fearful but more about
me being in a place where I get the
context of how did how to be present in
that moment with that human being or
study human beings so the Edgar Cayce
experience made me be very devoted
meditator through breathwork when I was
in my 20s and it took me to altered
states to I activated my Kundalini I had
a whole phase where I was there was a
lot of energy in my body I think it was
almost too powerful for me so it was
hard to hang on to it or trying to
scared me but I've always felt that I
benefit from a practice and that
practice is probably in a conference
where you see tech in the name of the
car
reference that the oldest mind-altering
technology is meditation
just like the ancient technology it
never goes out of date yeah okay
and for me personally any of the other
technology which is very legitimate at
this conference neurofeedback
photobiomodulation beds that create
energy waves I need to have this core
practice part of it and I view the other
technology as a way to supplement okay
is the most upstream issue our feelings
of separation our lack of
interconnectedness I believe that
fundamentally human beings are the
separation anxiety from your mother or
from a higher existence is the
fundamental thing we have to resolve in
our lives yes I really do and what are
your key dumb strategies you think boy
well I mentioned the practice I've been
kind of uh I would say I am an older guy
now I'm in my mid sixties so my life has
been trying to resolve this dilemma
because until you until you know that
you can exist there is like a a paradox
you need to exist as a self but you need
to also be connected and it's the
challenge of dealing with both of these
to be a non a anxious being so I did a
lot of work in my late 40s that involved
a coach and I had to begin to think of
myself as fundamentally ask the question
could I survive as itself without the
relationship so I was in it was not
because
I thought I was going to lose them but
it was being in relationship with other
people create certain obligations Ramos
wired to provide and I think there is a
dilemma for most human beings can I be
in an intimate relationship and still be
a self or do I surrender that to the the
idea of a fusion with another human
being
mm-hmm and the work was to not be fused
to my partner my wife
and I was very fearful if I did that
there wouldn't be a relationship and it
was exactly the opposite
the more I could be a whole self the
more was available to be in the
relationship because I could risk more
it was actually it for me it was a
beautiful unfolding so that was kind of
a different type of practice to stay
calm during that work I did I added an
interesting technology beyond the
ancient practice I began to do neural
feedback and the neural feedback was to
allow my brainwaves to normalize where
there was a little less anxiety and I
find anxiety is kind of the it's very
prevalent in society I think now I think
we're in kind of a regression so I view
some of this technology can reduce that
my practice can reduce it but for me
going back to this story to give the
punchline there was one or two very
intense experiences that I can only
describe as almost going beyond the
framework it was like an ayahuasca
experience without the ayahuasca where I
knew on a fundamental level I could
survive even if I was alone in the world
and in saying that the language is
nothing compared to the experience and
it was one of at the conclusion of it
I'd been given a freedom
yeah because the freedom is that if
you're beholding other relationships
because you're worried about the
reciprocity which is the attachment
issue you're not free to be all who you
are
mm-hmm right and when I had that freedom
to be more at risk rather than giving me
the freedom to leave relationships who
gave me the freedom to be more present
in them and the the energy and the
relationships began to grow it wasn't
beautiful it was a turning point for me
so I I think I'm giving you my own kind
of response yeah
to your question which I think you're
asking it on maybe a more esoteric level
than I'm responding your responses are
examples and you know yeah this is this
is my example for my life it's my choice
yes yes which is yes and deeply resonant
resonates and then what is the overall
purpose of this creation I think it's to
be in balance between being itself and
being connected I think dealing with the
duality mm-hm
I really do and I think that's the the
journey of my own whose that's the play
point there's a play one the play point
is both is dealing with the duality of
being seemingly separate of dealing with
the illusion as that separation yes
that's the play point that is this play
you've got it that's the dance of life
to me
fundamentally and in a way becoming less
attached in a way that lets you have
your freedom to be present in the world
without reaching without reaching or
without avoidance and I when I look at
myself as am I in phloem and life I do
an exercise every evening I look over
the day so tonight when I go to bed
the fact we're having this conversation
now
I will retrieve it along with other
conversations I've had in I'll ask and I
will then do it assessment of the energy
I had in the conversation was i reaching
to be to a proof that i want your
approval more was I trying to fix
something in you or was there something
that emerged that actually I avoided
dealing with it right and I became a
little more distant I just want to be
aware of that and is very subtle but to
me it's whether there's flow and whether
I was being truthful and present to my
own feelings and to you out of respect
for you so there it's an exercise it
takes yeah hmm I mean I can do a day in
probably five minutes and to me it's
being truthful to what was true for me
right it's about me and relationship to
myself and then I I'm aware of where did
I again reach too far where did I avoid
note it then is there something to fix
it is a fix in the relationship or is in
me being aware of my behavior and if I
did reach or I've avoided
what was I fearing and was that fear a
reality or not
what's been remarkable in this little
practice of mine is many times when
there is something that made me react as
I feared the next day I will go and
reach out to that person and have an
experiment of the thing I want avoided I
will then face with them yeah and then I
can look to see if the reaction I
thought that was happening actually
happened or not so I create a really
interesting causality if you do this
long enough you get a lot clearer yes
it's a this to me is my in the world
practice
right yes with me being truthful to
myself and having this this is me
John Hayworth cammack having his honest
of relationship with my inner self as I
can to be clarity because I think
clarity is the power of being present
without attachment right and that that
can create for people that will do the
work I think that where that comes to be
is as I aged with this is the grace of
being in the world in a certain way that
is easier for me right I don't carry the
burdens of other people or my own burden
and if one fine set then I actually I
think with you there's a little moment
of Sarah I'm feeling a moment of
serendipity right Serendipity's there
are beautiful little occasions that make
me feel the power of my god you know
that cares about us yes and you can let
us have moments where we can feel
complete love for another human being
and for ourselves
yes almost as though there's a warm
cuddling that's happening at those times
this is to love yourself for being who
you are with all my or your flaws
because the the respect I have for
myself as a soul making a journey yeah
right and the journeys kind of messy you
know because we got a deal with other
human beings we got a deal with our own
response just every time I do this
exercise is like taking a silk cloth in
rubbing it against the stone and the
stone is all my patterns and behavior
but if you do it gently
and you do it consistently you become a
slightly more graceful being in the
world and then with that clarity I have
found the freedom to go to
different states because if you can have
love this is about because what replaces
the fear is an acceptance of the moment
this the extraordinary again another
paradox the beauty that comes even when
there's pain or suffering yeah that
beauty and suffering can coexist
it's the ability to deal with complex
paradox yes yes it does not rob you of
your ability to be present with it yeah
that's right yeah so I'm gonna take this
a step further because I'm feeling like
we're having a good conference is so I'm
67 years old I'm accepting my mortality
and what I just described to you now has
become my practice of how I will be what
I want to leave when I leave the planet
that's it that's the last moment of
consciousness I and I only really
realize this about a year ago that this
practice was about how to be my practice
my way of being most effective of being
a graceful being on the planet in this
life but it also was the way to release
when it's time to go right
yeah where there's a little choice and
again the paradox will be there you have
you're alive and you will be moving on
right there are people you love you'll
be leaving them right you know to be
able to hold that place yeah right and I
can see my journey taking me there
because it will come and it's and it's
okay this is the other thing it's okay
you actually see the beauty in it oh my
god yeah yeah whereas the complete
opposite is the fear in it
well I didn't realize I was doing this
to prepare for this but now I can see
that it is part of my work and it is and
I didn't this is not what I thought the
outcome would be because when you're
younger you don't really attach to the
end but there's a point in one's life
where this becomes accepting one's own
death is probably that when we go back
to attachment how much attachment has
had to being alive
right it's like the greatest insanity
that we the state will be the state
forever yeah so I I have this there's a
beautiful little app out called you're
gonna die mm-hmm have you seen the app
you're gonna die there there may be
another one that we use called we croak
which we croak that's the one so I'm a
power user of we croak it's a great one
yeah and we croak gives you what five
five a day little reminders that I'm
gonna die right
and they're beautiful little vignettes
usually a sentence or two or a paragraph
so not only do do I do this but my wife
I've been married to for 31 years we
read these to each other Wow so I did my
own little inner journey and work but
here's my life partner and in reading
these to one another we're recognizing
this is our journey and it will we both
this is an inevitable thing and it's
preparing us for again together but we
will separate together and separate the
the duality again we're one but we're
separate and death will create that
separation at least in this state of
consciousness and it's brought this
vividness of
the how magnificent it is to have a day
another day to be present in conscious
where the little things suddenly start
to become magical yeah because you're
there and you're aware the the leaf
leaving the tree going to the ground
becomes because you're there in this
body seeing that and I in my time with
her I appreciate that but it said all
things must end
is it exercise an attachment and it's
intensified at least in my case the the
joy the the gift you're given if you
become aware that is the presence of
being but not needing it forever yeah
being able to let go so yeah so that's
kind of my spiritual journey and I can
do out-of-body experiences and lucid
dreaming and things like that but those
are the the cherry on the top of the
sundae experiences I think for me it's
been the work of the 40-year practice to
even to be able to articulate to you
this inner life of mine which has given
me the ability to deal with duality on a
day-to-day basis a little more
gracefully yes yes so this exact key
here that has been communicated which is
the gracefulness of dealing with the
duality dealing with the illusion of
separation from the one dealing with
this this key how to gracefully unite
with the one on a moment-to-moment basis
and also have some sort of ability to
learn these lessons that you've been
communicating to us
this one of all things end that this
that this that this you know we just had
Jim Doty on the shown here was saying no
beginning no end no separation and that
was very interesting as well mm-hmm so
that kind of also in a sense yes we and
in a physical potential incarnation
mm-hmm but nothing ever ends this
recording ends but creation continues
creating and becoming more alive so
there is no end I'm I'm not sure what I
believe about that I'm I'm kind of an
unresolved on I think there is a higher
I believe there's a higher self but I
got to admit I'm going through an
existential crisis on and by sure or is
it something else so I try to simplify
this I have a practice it gives me peace
it gives me clarity I think I have an
operating model of the context of what
I'm doing I know there are higher states
of consciousness because I had my
moments and the moments are the higher I
go the more I feel mm-hmm I feel
connected to a broader and broader part
of the world around me yes yes right yep
and it and by that is you are aware of
yourself you're aware of all the life
around you yes exactly yeah and what I
don't know is that when I leave my body
is that where I go or do I go to the
astral plane or do I go wherever my
karma will take me you know that will be
the great adventure right
I'd like that I'd like to have transfect
give me a little eyewear what are you
talking about say again what I what I
are you referencing when you say where
you go next what I my awareness isn't
this all your awareness it is yes this
is all our awareness you had under
collective yes yes this is all creation
experiencing itself so when you say
where does the I go next
it gets reabsorbed what would you say
more aliveness could it be that on the
other side of death of this incarnation
is actually more aliveness and that this
itself is the most beautiful thing
possible this is the most beautiful
thing possible for creation to create
where we can feel the illusion of that
separation and play and all be that and
feel that and experience it through each
other through the interconnectedness of
all this mate there may may be nothing
possibly more beautiful than this it's
maybe the only impossible it may be the
only impossible nothing else being more
impossible nothing else being impossible
except something being more beautiful
than creation then what this is well I'm
prepared to say again I'm going to speak
from experience that I would agree with
you that there have been moments of my
life where the beauty is more available
to me in the connectivity yeah I think
we're all seekers for that I would think
that
I do believe that if there is a
consciousness beyond this life the work
we all do in this life will be reflected
in the level of availability to that
beauty we move towards and we're all
seeking down towards it
yes I believe this world this universe
is it had to be created by a higher
consciousness it's just so remarkable
yeah and that the fun about and you go
back to the earlier question around
separation we separated from that
consciousness at one point and we
separate you separate from your mother
separate from that conscience you're
working to kind of resolve that through
practice or maturity emotional maturity
and it's kind of the hero's journey in
another way is getting back right yeah
yeah yeah so I kind of think again when
you go to trans packets for me I'm only
interested in the companies that aid the
journey yeah you know yeah and some of
them will be distractions from the
journey or how do you discern does it
create a greater connectivity where I'm
able to be in a place where I can more
freely express be aware of the
connectivity connection to myself
connection to another that allows me to
come out of my heart in a way that is
building a genuine residence with
another human being
starting with myself that
as it were frankly built on love right
mmm and something so because I think
there can be a performance part of this
like I want to be better what I want to
be able to work harder than somebody
else at Google it's like that's a
materialism having a brain that can do
more and can compete better I kind of
like it where it's I become a deeper
richer person and then from that place
I'll use other technologies that allow
me to build relationship with others at
Lieb net a more civil world and a world
where there's less fear more love and
respect and more peace inner peace and
peace between human beings yeah that's
what I'm looking for
yeah
I'm curious how do you feel about the
next evolutionary step of consciousness
flowering in this creation the grad I
I'm not sure which way is going to go be
honest with you what are the ways that
you see well I can see an emergence of
individuals that desire a better world
that can be enabled by tools that let
them find their better self in their
higher self
let them reduce your anxiety again fear
is the opposite of love and can that
capacity to be brought to bear in ways
that let people apply it to kind of
societal issues where we heal the planet
and in doing that we heal ourselves and
you or do we we let the the forces of
fear which I think are very
institutionalized around the world and
in the u.s. part of the beauty of
creation itself I think there's a threat
that we're becoming more of a fear-based
society right now mm-hmm
and it plays out in politics it plays
out in race some of the race part is
historical and as a terrible legacy but
we need to get beyond that and we need
to heal and we need to you know we need
to know that we can love we can what
does it mean to love one another right
so I only met you an hour ago right yeah
so what and what in any of the seconds
we were together what was the right way
for me to be with you right so how do we
how do more people think about that and
not have the fear to act in the way that
brings out your better side to be
available and then it kind of compounds
yeah I think these things kind of spiral
in a way so butterfly effect out I do
III think it can be this I think it can
become an emergence right yeah
or it can become a regression where we
get more isolated in ourselves
fear becomes more than norm and begin to
blame other people for our own
unhappiness then we hold them
accountable for it and this is really
ugly this is the greatest challenge is
it creation right there right right and
it's playing out in our society so love
and fear on the Union young right there
I think it's being amplified right so we
need to have conferences like this
because we need to amplify the love the
love side and we can we need to release
eleven people so was it really discussed
at this conference I believe it will be
future conferences but I think the the
work of reintroducing some of these
ancient organics civil sidon and other
drugs that yeah is because I was there
in the 60s they have billions of years
of intelligence they have add they do in
the life forms that have used them have
a certain wisdom yeah right so and if
you look at the creative the reason LSD
was shut down was there was so many
people who are there creativity is
moving beyond the bounds of how society
was structured you threatened the
government yeah right so they decide
it's illegal
soon as it threatens the economic
machinery which is profiteering on
feelings of separation it is and that
that's why this regression because
there's too much profit from the media
even that the to play
local parties yeah be fearmongers to one
another one another so how do you offset
that I would like to think that in the
emergence of of these ancient organics
that allow one to reset if you really
look at what happens in the brain and
the default Network you and I are both
kind of wired in a way we all of us are
where our default network is kind of
sets two contexts and every respond to
pattern recognition in our lives I kind
of think of that is also the
accumulation of our Karma so yeah it and
if you've done the work working off your
Karma
how long does this take okay why and how
many spins around the Sun does it take
right yeah so maybe these ancient
compounds have been given to us to give
us some freedom to do resets a little
bit faster
these still got do the work yes still
got up and Furion you got to do it in a
in a context of trust and love to find
your higher-self yeah right and slow
your demons but but maybe I almost think
that the reintroduction of these both
underground and legal could let a
generation of people begin to redefine
the relationships you want with yourself
with one another and with the planet
yeah the planet the planetary
consciousness that has yet to emerge and
response to global climate change yeah I
personally have a hope and a hypothesis
these organic compounds is a gift that
will let us redefine the relationship we
want to mother earth you know in
ourselves and it will be a renaissance
yeah that's the hope I yeah I to bed
every night yeah yeah John thank you so
much for coming on our show and talking
to us about this this has been deeply
profound thank you it was an honor to be
with you and with you thank you thank
you thanks everyone for two and
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on that but so let us know what you're
thinking about all these incredible
points please let us know in the
comments check out the links in the bio
below two more of John's work check out
links in the bio below the
transformative technology conference
Thank You Brady sperm for Co producing
the show we really appreciate your
brother thank you and also support the
artists T entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders organizations around the world
and in your communities that you believe
in you can find our links below to our
show
PayPal patreon cryptocurrency please
support us and help us continue growing
our reach with this kind of content and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]